So now all of a sudden in the wake of the
Trump Ukraine whistleblower Biden scandal,
as we are sort of calling it democratic speaker
of the house, Nancy Pelosi is considering
impeaching Donald Trump.
There's a Washington post report, very detailed
that, uh, Nancy Pelosi up until last night
on the phone quietly sort of feeling out house
Democrats about whether to start an impeachment
inquiry as a result of this.
Most recent scandal involving Donald Trump
and Ukraine and Joe bide.
Now, to remind you my position on this, my
position on on impeachment has been a sort
of a, a neutral in the sense that I'm fine
doing it.
I'm fine not doing it, but a decision has
to be made and whether there is or isn't going
to be an impeachment inquiry, Democrats need
to move forward on how to win in 2020 regardless
of what the impeachment decision is.
Either use the impeachment inquiry to try
to win in 2020 or say we're not doing the
impeachment inquiry and figure out how to
win in 2020 anyway.
Now, according to multiple senior house Democrats
and congressional AIDS, Nancy Pelosi is asking
around, is this Ukraine thing, the tipping
point, making phone calls all day yesterday
up to last night.
And there's a key line from this Washington
post report about this story, which is that
there are now many leadership AIDS who once
thought Donald Trump's impeachment was unlikely
who are now saying they believe it to be almost
inevitable.
Remember that Nancy Pelosi's previous position
was, Oh, impeachment will be too divisive.
So the question is what has changed and what
has changed is the Ukraine story, which pulls
together collusion, bribery, geopolitical
extortion, suppression of whistleblowers,
and this is extending interest in impeachment
reportedly beyond just like the liberal base
of house Democrats to more centrist Democrats
as well.
Democrats are admitting that the sort of tone
and tenor of conversations around impeachment
have changed since the Ukraine story broke,
and although nothing has been finalized, it's
important to remember that even if an MP impeachment
inquiry did start, it could take some time,
which I don't think is bad.
I've said before, the decision about the impeachment
inquiry should be made.
The timing of it might be calculated to be
more damaging to Trump if it's delayed a little
bit until you know, maybe early 2020 would
be the latest that I think it would make sense
to start it.
But then you also see Democrats wasting time
with certain things around the Ukraine story.
Here's an example.
House Democrats are now planning to hold a
vote on a resolution to maybe condemn Donald
Trump's actions in regard to this Ukraine
Joe Biden thing.
It's just a milk toast, irrelevant thing.
I mean, truly, I get it.
You know, you get something on the record,
but the, this, this, it's just a waste.
You're not gonna do anything with that.
And the idea of Ukraine as the tipping point,
if international extortion of other countries
for the benefit of Donald Trump's 2020 election
chances by getting Ukraine to smear Biden
is not a tipping point.
Something is very wrong.
But we already had many of what should have
been tipping points in the past already.
The firing of the FBI director James Comey,
Donald Trump's eight obstructive acts, Donald
Trump's supporting the Saudi war on Yemen,
the financial crimes and coverups, I mean
to say we are now at a tipping point is accurate.
But it also ignores that we've had a number
of tipping points already.
So what we get to in the end is that Nancy
Pelosi now reconsidering impeachment, it's
just the political calculation.
Don't be tricked into thinking that what Nancy
Pelosi is calculating is whether what Donald
Trump has done is bad enough to justify an
impeachment inquiry or impeachment proceedings.
They want us to think that they're evaluating
whether what Trump did is bad enough to justify
impeachment.
What they're really doing and what Nancy Pelosi
is doing is calculating whether politically
impeachment is likely to be a successful move.
And when I say successful, I don't mean removing
Trump before the November, 2020 election with
Republicans controlling the Senate.
You're not going to remove Donald Trump through
impeachment.
The question is, would impeachment be successful
in the sense of being welcomed as the correct
move by the public?
Would it be potentially beneficial for the
2020 election?
That is what Nancy Pelosi is now considering
and I want to hear from you.
What do you think?
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show.
I've asked before, I've said before I could
go either way on impeachment.
The question is what is the right calculation
to be making?
Do you believe the right calculation to be
making is a political one?
Is it a moral one?
Is it illegal?
One?
Let me know on Twitter at D Pacman.
I will also be streaming this evil
getting on Twitch at twitch.tv/david Pakman.
Make sure that you're following me there as
well.